on est pas mieux qu'à Paris
ici le bois aussi est à vous mais vous
pouvez pas empêcher les gens de se
promener dedans c'est rien bonjour voir
les Parisiens vous savez on est plus
parisien on a emménagé là ça change tout
en tout cas si vous avez besoin de quoi
que ce soit n'hésitez pas c'est génial
bonjour la campagne c'est pas comme dans
les grandes villes on est
solidaire
non
désolé vous inquiétez pas parce que la
chasse c'est mi-septembre mi- février
donc c'est pas non plus 5 mois mi
février c'est un petit
mois bon tout le monde est là le mot
d'ordre c'est la sécurité
compris André merde j'appelle mon père
il sortent les fusils on sort le pasa
votre problème c'est que vous avez
quitté les fous de Paris pour les tarés
de la
campagne
jou vous allez vous trouver un terrain
d'entente entre gens intelligents c'est
bien ma chérie c'est
bien vive la chasse la chasse au
Parisien ils ont mis du maïs dans jardin
les pour les attirer dégage je
pense qu'il y a un petit risque
d'escalade attendez c'est pas une
servitude ça c'est un terrain de chasse
si je vous l'avais dit vous l'urriez
acheté B non et ben
voilà